hey can i ask you a quick question
go right ahead i'm thinking of starting
the dark tower but everyone has their
own complicated reading order so i was
just
wondering can i just start with the
gunslinger of course
it's the perfect place to start then
drawing of the three
fine then the wastelands no what do you
mean it's the
it's the third book in the series well
you you need to read the stand black
house the talisman at least
before continuing okay then wizard and
glass
naturally then salem slot but isn't that
like a totally different the eyes of the
dragon everything's eventual hearthstone
atlantis
and it it isn't that like a thousand
pages it ties in it ties up stephen
king's universe is vast and complex
to catch the entirety of the dark tower
series you need
complete context okay well then what
order do you suggest well
i'd start with carrie then salem's lot
the shining
the stand the long walk the dead zone
fire starter you're just naming every
stephen king book in publication order
look if you want the easy route maybe
the series isn't for you
wait wait wait wait wait okay after
after wizard and glass
the wind through the keyhole from a
buick eight desperation the regulators
insomnia do i have to read insomnia if
you want to live
what what okay what next i'll finish the
series 567 wolves susannah the dark
tower
then i'm done
then you're done
[Music]
i like to read the gunslinger at the end
just to put a nice bow on everything do
i really have to read insomnia
yeah actually that one that one is
pretty important